[Musique]
on a constaté une recrudescence de mer
et d'élus des missionnaires sur
l'ensemble des territoires de France et
notre volonté c'est vraiment d'essayer
d'observer pourquoi cette recrudescence
de démission et surtout de pouvoir au
travers des préconisations qui seront
formulées dans cette mission d'apporter
des solutions
pragmatiques pour redonner du souffle à
la commune et bien sûr recréer
ressusciter des dévocations c'est une
mission où on va essayer d'aller au plus
près des problématiques des élus donc
déjà essayé aussi d'aller rencontrer les
mères qui ne se sont pas représentés et
elle est aussi les maires qui ont
démissionné depuis 2020 et puis d'avoir
aussi une faculté à sonder nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens français
pour savoir ce qu'ils attendent de leur
mairie de leur mère de leurs élus et de
ce lien de proximité entre la commune et
le citoyen depuis 10 ans on a eu ces
réformes territoriales qui sont venus un
petit peu
exécuter le travail que pouvait faire
les mères au jour le jour on a le
sentiment qui n'y trouve plus de sens
dans ce qu'ils font si un maire doit
rester pendant un mandat pour simplement
signer des actes d'état civil et gérer
le cimetière c'est pas une bonne chose
on peut comprendre que ça n'attire plus
personne il y a aussi un principe de
différenciation territoriale les maires
et les élus vivent comme l'ensemble des
Françaises des Français des réalités qui
sont différentes en milieu urbain en
milieu rural c'est la multiplication des
normes aussi cet alourdissement du
travail du maire moi je sais j'étais
mère en 2001 et je l'étais jusqu'en 2017
c'était plus facile d'être mère en 2001
qu'en 2017
[Musique]